Heather starts us off this hour in
Orlando Florida hi Heather how are you
hi Dave it's an honor to talk to you you
too what's up in your world I'm quick
shout out a shout out to the YouTube
crazies I've been listening to you since
for like three years there's this
recently about a year ago whenever the
YouTube channel started thank you
thanks my question we're on baby step
two my Valentine's Day get to my husband
last year was your class and he didn't
really like it but then after the first
class he was hooked so we pay you off
about $13,000 since February of 16 and I
decided I was going to get another job
this year I'm a CEO for seasonal and I'm
bringing in extra thirteen thousand
dollars over the next three and a half
months ambition to our normal income and
I got a raise
problem and my husband was getting all
motivated because I'm working till
midnight every night I do 12-hour days
he decided to list his Mustang which was
a really big deal
we have extra cars and all of a sudden
he told me I don't want to lift the
Mustang anymore I don't know if and I'm
just getting frustrated I need some
motivation here and I control the bank
account because I'm an accountant so I'm
paying this stuff down about $90,000 in
debt and I'm and I think the numbers
what's freaking him out a little bit
you're doing it wrong you didn't do what
I told you there we didn't teach you to
control the bank account which is a
married couple to do a budget together
we do the budget that I mean like he
doesn't pay the bills like I take the
budget and I do all the payments and he
does he understand the budget he looks
at it every single month and he knows
what bills you're going to pay yes
and so when you say I control the bank
account you don't really control the
bank account you are merely the
bookkeeper for the Budget Committee and
you're a member of the Budget Committee
is that right correct I'm sorry I want
to make sure because I thought I was
figuring out why he was bailing here cuz
I have no emotional investment okay but
he's sitting there looking at the
numbers with you and then and now he
wants to just do nothing and then
join me I'm sitting in yeah we're in the
money and you know let's just enjoy it
and you know his dad just was diagnosed
with dementia so he's like we're going
to retire with all this money and I'll
be not able to really enjoy it and I
just want to give them right through it
since I'm going to be having this extra
income no well he remembers a Financial
Peace University it sounds like you need
to go back through in my spare time
right now well in his spare time he's
the one that needs some encouragement
because he you know the comment you just
gave me was that of a four year old I'm
gonna stick my lip out and just go win
yeah when and now you're calling me up
like you're a four-year-olds mommy
really you know that's what that's
what's going on in this relationship and
so the two of you need to sit down again
and go okay honey
we got this we got this let's go back
through Financial Peace University let's
let's reset our minds on this it's been
a hard year we were working a lot of
hours we're doing a lot of stuff and if
you want to hold the Mustang that's fine
but I mean that was a nice thing it
looked to me like you were really on
board and you were you know we were
doing stuff here but if you want to hold
it that's fine let's go back to this
class and reset our reason for doing
this the reason we were doing this baby
if you remember was $90,000 in debt
sucks and I don't like living like this
and you know you need to have the talk
about why we're doing it again
because he's run out of emotional steam
it sounds like and so you know and maybe
Financial Peace University going back
through it helps you know I don't think
you're going to make it till May or I
would give you two tickets for the Dave
Ramsey Chris Hogan them in and May I'll
give you those two anyway but you got to
do something before May because by May
you're going to be you won't even come
to the smart money event I'll give you
two tickets but by then you know it's
you're going to be off in a ditch
somewhere with what you're describing so
we gotta do something get the wambulance
stopped here that's that's what we've
got to do so I'd recommend you go back
to the Financial Peace University in the
meantime hold on and I'll have Kelly
pick up and she'll give you two tickets
to the event maybe that'll just let him
know that you know hey we're doing this
we're doing this hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]